dr michael morbius the smash hit morbius
now out in theaters sweeping the world
morbius sweep now is getting the pitch
meeting treatment from ryan george
do you guys think that there was a
problem with the computer you're like
what the buffer what's happening oh do
you two need to see reaction hey
you should be ashamed of yourselves
[Music]
so you have a movie for me yes sir i do
so i was thinking we keep making our way
down the list of marvel characters sony
can still use oh hell yeah we're
basically in the mcu now did you know
yeah i mean everybody in this building
keeps telling me that with big smiles on
their faces but with one eye twitching
for some reason we're pretty much a part
of marvel's studios did you know that
yeah all right sir so i was thinking we
make a movie about morbius i love it hey
let's get some spider-man involved in
here actually he doesn't have much to do
with the script i've written here but
we're allowed to do it so let's do it
let's put like a spider-man poster in
the background or something people are
going to go nuts okay and then we put
that in the trailer but it's not going
to make sense in the movie
we don't have to put it in the movie as
long as it's in the trailer that's what
matters kind of feels like false
advertising yeah let's do some of that
that sounds great well okay then i'm not
gonna lie i still think that's some of
the most messed up advertising
for a lawsuit to have like i feel like
it's the one time where you could argue
that legitimately they learned all the
wrong lessons from what marvel tends to
do dr michael morbius has this rare
blood disorder and he's gonna die
probably uh-oh but then he develops a
potential cure by combining human dna
and vampire bad dna sounds super power
origin-y it is but then he tests this
thing on himself on a ship in
international waters and turns himself
into a vampire oh yeah so now instead of
being all sick and thin he's jacked and
muscular you know like a bat that's not
really what bats are known for but i'm
glad you're excited dude's freaking
shredded now he's got like a six-pack
looks like a calvin klein underwear
model you know like a bat okay cool what
kind of bats you've been looking at
someone more sexy ones he's gonna kill a
bunch of mercenaries on this boat just
tear them to shreds there's going to be
blood everywhere pg-13 there's going to
be blood sound effects everywhere
some of the worst parts throughout his
powers he's got like back sonar he's
very strong his nose goes upwards air
super powered upward noses are tight but
he's got to drink blood every six hours
or he's gonna get sick again and lose
his bat six-pack oh no so he's gotta
keep killing people no cause we want
morbias to be a good guy so he's
drinking this synthetic blood he
developed oh okay great but he can feel
that that's not gonna sustain him
forever sooner or later he's gonna need
the real thing he's gonna be like you
won't like me when i'm hungry that's
kind of like the line from the other
thing it sure is certain kind of
wow wow so anyway more b is also
childhood friend milo who has the same
blood disorder and he wants to take the
cure too oh yeah understandable but
morbius is like no this is a curse so
you die and i'll figure this out
kinda this sick look
that is so true
yeah because all things considered it
seemed like
it seemed like michael morbius was on
the path to at least figuring this out
okay you managed to cure yourself and
you're stronger and sexier than ever
there's a few kinks just gotta uproot a
few cakes and we're on our way i mean
you spent like 40 years trying to fix
one thing maybe just spend like another
couple weeks trying to figure out the
next and maybe your beloved best friend
won't turn into like a blood-hungry evil
guy if you just help him out with some
of your synthetic blood fix give him
that chance at least
and also there's this sick little girl
that morbius is taking care of at a
certain point he's gonna have to put her
into a coma oh is she gonna be okay i
don't know you don't no he puts her in a
coma i completely forgot that storyline
oh okay well
i hope she pulls through me too so
eventually milo does take the injection
thing and then he frames morbius for a
vampire murder of a nurse why is he an
evil vampire because the movie needs a
bad guy now that makes sense so morbius
gets chased by the police and these fbi
guys that's what it's really on top of a
roof very exciting and then once he's up
there one of the fbi guys pulls a gun
and is like enough have the fbi guy get
up there so fast unclear okay so morbius
ends up breaking out of jail and now
he's on the run thrilling and at a
certain point his assistant slash love
interest cause they're both attractive
is being followed by the fbi uh-oh and
she manages to lose them and gets on a
bus and morbius is already on that bus
how did he know she was gonna get on
that bus and get on it before her i
don't know fair enough but he's got no
choice but to talk to her all secret
like you know he's a wanted man of
course so anyway they go sit in a coffee
shop and have a little chat but i
thought you just said they needed to be
like incognito oh yeah sir that was in
the bus scene this is a different scene
now so that doesn't matter anymore oh
okay and then morbius over here some bad
logic how about this lab they run so he
goes and hijacks it from them oh you
know what he should scare one of the
guys and be like i'm venom right okay
that doesn't really make sense but we're
allowed to do that we should do that
it's just even if this is in the same
universe we've never made it seem like
the average citizen knows the name venom
but that's an interconnected thing that
we can do and it'll be good in the
trailer all right anyway so then
morpheus uses this lab to create a new
injection and he's like bats this is
lethal to humans it's deadly
so his plan
[Laughter]
his responsibility because he's turning
into a vampire you know he's gonna have
to kill people eventually wow very
selfless you know that's a good that's a
good sacrifice then there's gonna be
this big fight between milo and morbius
and then what's gonna happen oh a whole
bunch of stuff i'm almost sure of it
it's gonna be pretty impossible to see
but they're gonna start on a roof and
end up in a sewer oh nice and now
morbius has to find a way to kill this
guy is that gonna be hard to do actually
it's gonna be super easy barely an
inconvenience oh really you see he does
like a dragon ball z move and shoots a
bunch of bats at milo and then injects
him with the thing he can do that yeah
because see because of the gene slicing
bat human dna injection the bats seem
morbius as a brother didn't milo inject
himself at the same time he did okay so
yeah that worked out great and so then
morbius injects himself why would he
inject himself that would kill him
because of that thing where he said it's
his responsibility because he's gonna
drink human blood oh yeah no sir that's
from a previous scene you keep
referencing things characters did or
said earlier in the movie you don't have
to do that see like this is what i mean
when i said it was fine i feel like
it's fine
we're laughing at this movie so much and
we were watching it but i don't know for
some reason i'm like
nah it's still not as horrible as a
roommate to me that's where i keep going
with it like that's stupid fun i'm
enjoying it yeah it's fine enough that
all the stupid and silly decisions and
things that don't make sense just don't
make me mad
yet it's not exactly so bad it's good
yeah it's not really so anything enough
to be good or just fine it's just yeah
and all these things are so true it's a
possible way to spend an hour and 40
minutes like when i'm watching this i'm
noticing so many things ryan's pointing
out but i'm like ah
now whatever let's move on
kind of like the movie's attitude keep
referencing things characters did or
said earlier in the movie you don't have
to do that oh my bad pretty much every
scene is a clean slate here oh also his
assistant she's a vampire now cause why
not yeah why not and so that's about it
what do you think well it sounds like a
good time but needs more spider-man
references for sure well okay uh i'll
tell you what we can use that doctor
strange spell from no way home as an
excuse to get vulture in this thing
vulture yeah we could just have him kind
of pop up in a jail cell and be like
i hope the food's better in this joint
that's not really how doctor strange's
spell works then they can just let him
out of jail because he hasn't done
anything wrong in this universe
technically right so then he can fly in
with his vulture suit and meet up with
morbius how does he have a vulture suit
in this universe and he can be like not
sure how i got here has something to do
with spider-man i think i think that
suit was made with alien tech from the
first avengers movie so he doesn't have
access then he could be like i'm still
figuring this place out but i think a
bunch of guys like us should team up and
do some good and then morbius can be
like
intriguing that's okay none of that
really makes sense at all it doesn't
matter now we can put vulture in the
trailer it's all connected we're part of
marvel studios do you want me to spruce
up any of that dialogue no not even
worth the effort all right amazing i
gotta say every once in a while you come
across a pitch meeting and you go
that might actually be how the real
pitch meeting went down that's exactly
what i was thinking who should we get to
play morbius well tell you what i hear
jared leto's looking for a new superhero
project to kind of redeem himself after
suicide squad oh this sounds like the
perfect project for that
oh boy guys subscribe to pitch meeting
youtube channel not screwdrived i mean
you can if you want to don't and don't
ever go to screen screen ride yourself
he's mad at this
yeah that's our chat for this so yeah
subscribe to pitch meeting whenever you
can movies like this were made for pitch
meetings amen to that sister another
fantastic job you can check out our if
you've had many a coverage videos hey
let's do a pic
lance door lance i wanted to shout you
out because i was thinking who would be
a perfect person to be vampire buddies
with
you man
but then i thought about it some more to
be terrible you see because you're a
firefighter and
vampires they don't do well around fire
very much
no you're tempted fate buddy i have this
whole thing about like hey hanging out
with my friend while we're going through
the night and uh you know messing with
fire hydrants and feeding off of people
because all the firefighters were
24-hour shifts another reason why it
probably wouldn't be a good idea because
we probably have to work during the day
god forbid we get put on a call might be
a little bit difficult so really you are
not the ideal person to be vampire
buddies with lance
but thanks for being at our patreon page
for so long
[Music]
you